.
♪♪♪
- Le légendaire groupe suédois
ABBA est de retour! Benny
et Bjorn en ont fait l'annonce
aujourd'hui durant un événement
en direct de Londres
et diffusé sur Youtube.
Ils ont dévoilé 10 nouvelles
chansons qui seront réunies
sur un album intitulé "Voyage".
♪♪♪
Un grand retour attendu pendant
4 décennies. En plus du nouveau
disque, ABBA a également annoncé
la création d'un nouveau
spectacle, qui mettra
en vedette, sur scène,
des hologrammes des quatre
membres du groupe qui sont
désormais septuagénaires.
Des personnages qu'il baptisent
des "Abbatar" et qui ont été
créés par une équipe de plus
de 500 artistes et experts
en effets spéciaux.
Les concerts seront présentés
à Londres à compter du 27 mai,
à l'ABBA Arena, une nouvelle
salle de 3000 places conçue
spécialement pour accueillir
ce concert.
Les membres d'ABBA expliquent
que l'idée à commencé à germer
en 2018, lorsqu'ils ont décidé
d'enregistrer deux nouveaux
titre. Constatant que la magie
continuait d'opérer, ils ont
décidé de faire tout un album.
Au cours de leur carrière,
ils ont vendu près
de 400 millions d'albums
à travers le monde, obtenu
17 numéros 1 et récoltent chaque
semaine plus de 16 millions
d'écoutes sur les plateformes
en continu. Sans compter
la comédie musicale et les films
"Mamma Mia!" inspirés
des chansons d'ABBA et qui ont
été de grands succès.
La magie d'ABBA continue
d'opérer. Et si on se fie
aux premières réactions,
cette réunion d'ABBA
devrait faire un tabac.
Ici Nabi-Alexandre Chartier,
Radio-Canada, M